on parle beaucoup de l'Afrique mais en
fait c'est une notion qui est un peu
générale et on a tort de dire l'Afrique
parce que il y a pas une Afrique il y a
plusieurs Afrique il y a l'Afrique du
Nord dont vous venez il y a l'Afrique de
l'Ouest il y a l'Afrique de l'Est il y a
la fréquence australe elles ont toutes
ces Afriques et bien une vie et une
histoire différente
le très horizontal qui passerait au
niveau du Sahel donc de l'Atlantique à
la mer Noire et puis une verticale qui
partirait on va dire du Sahel jusqu'à
l'Afrique du Sud on a quatre régions
complètement différentes Le Locle
et musulman
et qui se rattache à une histoire qui
n'a rien d'Afrique
plutôt méditerranéen arabe et européenne
vous avez une Afrique du Sud de l'Ouest
et qui très occidentale très
occidentalisée à cause de la
colonisation à quoi ça colonisation
et puis la partie orientale qui est
complètement à l'opposé de l'Ouest et
l'accord de l'Afrique qui est plutôt sur
l'Inde sur l'Asie les tournées vers
l'Asie et c'est curieusement c'est que
on a pensé que
c'était la volonté de colonisateurs sont
faites comme ça c'est le partage de
territoire et que une fois les
indépendances acquises l'Afrique allait
vivre voyager échanger pas du tout tous
ces renforcé au contraire les les
dessins dans les deux sens du mot dessin
posé par les pays occidentaux sont
toujours là et renforcés
la France défend ces positions en
Afrique de l'Ouest et
ça le pré carré
alors ça commence à bouger ces dernières
années on sent par exemple le monde
arabe qui veut récupérer le Maghreb qui
lui avait totalement échappé après
l'école vous dites par exemple l'Afrique
de l'ouest elle est très occidentalisée
mais en fait l'Afrique de l'Ouest aussi
elle a pour religion l'Islam
majoritairement et cette Islam il est
venu d'une période où une espèce de
colonisation justement de ce qu'on a
appelé d'ailleurs la colonisation
orientale enfin ce sont les arabes qui
ont colonisé d'abord la frite noire
occidentale écoutez c'est très différent
l'islam est arrivé en Afrique du Nord
il s'est superposé à une religion c'est
le christianisme
donc il y avait déjà une structure une
base bien structurée sur les
métaphysique religieuses alors que dans
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et ces plaquée sur
des religions traditionnelles animistes
magiques on est dans et donc
en fait c'est d'ici là des islames très
différents alors mais il y a aussi ce
phénomène qui est absolument terrible
qui s'appelle l'esclavage et on parle
beaucoup de l'esclavagisme qui a été
entretenu par les Européens avec ce
commerce triangulaire mais avant cette
esclavagisme là il y a eu aussi ce qu'on
a appelé l'esclavagisme oriental
c'est-à-dire celui qui a été arabe arabe
et qui a été dénoncé d'ailleurs par un
grand écrivain qui s'appelle Yambo holo
game dans un livre qui s'appelle le
devoir de violence qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit d'ailleurs à l'époque
était un malien
il a dénoncé
cette esclavagiste en disant mais
attendez il a pénétration islamiste en
Afrique de l'ouest
elle est dû aux Arabes et en fait
l'esclavagisme européen est n'est qu'un
épisode là-dedans
ça lui a valu beaucoup de critiques et
bien écoutez
l'islam est venu avec cette idée que
si on ne se convertit pas à l'islam on
est mis en esclavage voilà donc on est
où tu es ou mis en esclavage donc il a
en arrivant
en Afrique il a donc d'abord chercher la
islamiser les gens ceux qui se sont
convertis
sont venus
ils sont rentrés dans la machine
esclavagiste eux-mêmes mais c'est vrai
que
l'esclavage dans le monde arabe est
énorme je veux dire que c'est dans un
rapport de 1 à 100 entre ce que
l'Occident a déplacé de population et ce
que le monde musulman aura déplacé il y
a eu plus de déplacés par le monde
musulman que par le monde occidental
énormément beaucoup plus beaucoup
plusieurs millions d'accord qui a
commencé très tôt continue
ça continue ou on parle beaucoup d'un
pays comme la Mauritanie où on dit qu'il
y a encore pas seulement la Mauritanie
vous venez en Algérie il y a des
baladez-vous et vous verrez
tous ces migrants qui viennent du sud du
Sahel mais de aussi et qui sont rendus à
l'état d'esclavage dans
l'esclavage moderne mais je veux dire
que ils sont
exploités dans des conditions absolument
abominables quoi voilà ils arrivent ils
partent à la clandestinité ils sont
récupérés par des NU grillés qui les
utilisant des chantiers
plus ou moins
officiel les goûts
ils acceptent cela eux ils sont dans une
perspective d'émigration vers le nord
d'accord juste un passage pour se faire
un peu d'argent
un transit et puis finalement ils sont
piégés là-dedans parce que ils sont
vraiment exploités
le gouvernement de temps en temps réagit
parce que évidemment les pays africains
se plaignent de
ce qui se passe de des mauvais
traitements que les pays du Maghreb
infligent assez migrants malheureusement
ça on en entend absolument pas parler
enfin dans les actualités
internationales c'est pas un fléau dont
on parle beaucoup le problème il est
occidental c'est que le occidentaux ont
de plus en plus peur de parler de de ce
qui est le en dehors de leur très carré
parce qu'ils ont peur d'être accusé de
racisme de
ils ont peur de parler de ce qui se
passe au Maroc de ce qui se passe en
Algérie de ce qui se passe en Tunisie
parce qu'on peut évidemment leur opposer
cela racisme mensonge manipulation
comme il n'y a pas d'enquête on peut
tout dire et le contraire combien
d'Afrique un mois je sais que dans le
seul quartier où j'habite j'envoie des
dizaines et des dizaines tous les jours
les Subsahariens des Noirs africains
voilà alors justement vous dites les
Occidentaux ça ils en parlent pas parce
qu'ils ont peur d'être accusé de racisme
les relations entre la France et
l'Algérie sont des relations on ne peut
plus compliquer évidemment
se passer il passe pas à se passer
je vais vous dire le fond de ma pensée
ce passé ne passera
pas tant que les nos pays sont notamment
l'Algérie sont des
membres des états de droit démocratiques
voilà il faut que les Algériens puissent
les Maghrébins puis se s'exprimer
librement pour que la relation à l'autre
d'une manière générale les Français les
Allemands les Africains deviennent une
relation normale parce que c'est
tabissant sur le dialogue sur la
discussion on peut pas discuter comment
voulez-vous qu'on s'entende aussi
longtemps que l'Algérie soit gouverné
par des autocrates on n'a pas le droit
de parler donc on est tenu de tenir le
discours de la de la doxa le discours
officiel voilà il faut être vraiment
l'opposant qui
vit à l'extérieur et qui alors vous qui
avez la d'entrée dure avec le régime
algérien avec le FLN et avec les je
dirais des successeurs du FLN même si
certains perds de la révolution sont
encore là
comment vous avez réagi quand en 2005
par exemple et bien il y a eu un projet
de loi en France pour reconnaître les
bienfaits de la colonisation c'est un
projet de loi qui était inspiré par la
droite à l'époque qui était au pouvoir
sous Jacques Chirac ça a fait énormément
de évidemment ça crée une polémique
terrible parce que
les bienfaits de la colonisation bon on
sait que ça délimite quand même
comment vous avez réagi à ça vous ce qui
est malheureux c'est c'est le mot
bienfait
le mot était maladroit le mot est
maladroit
bien sûr renvoie peut-être à une notion
quasi religieuse quoi
bien fait bienfaiteur etc non il y a une
réalité historique bon la France est
venue s'est installé en Algérie elle a
fait il faut faire un bilan l'actif et
le passif
le passé fait évidemment est très lourd
c'est un cours la colonisation s'est
faite par des moyens essentiellement
militaires par la suite c'est poursuivi
pendant plusieurs d'autres méthodes
l'éducation
voilà la colonisation Jules Ferry je
dirais on apporte la civilisation on
peut inspiré par les sentiments tout ça
il faut voilà il faut considérer
l'économiser comme étant des partenaires
etc
et donc sur cet mode là sur ce plan
je pourrais presque reprendre un peu
l'expression de Macron qui parlait de
ruissellement
en parlant de la France là pour le coup
la France a beaucoup investi pour elle
évidemment
son nouveau territoire donc un
investissait chez elle pour les siens
mais paruissellement les autochtones
notamment le citadins on en profiter
d'accord moi je fais partie de ces que
de ceux qui ont profité cela
ma mère était infirmière à l'hôpital
grand hôpital Mustapha d'Alger mon
grand-père était chef de gare tout ça
c'est grâce à la colonisation
c'est
pas grave c'est le ruissellement si le
ruissellement d'accord j'en profiter et
néanmoins en revanche qui n'ont pas qui
ont été
perdus dans dans ce mouvement ce sont
les les campagnards qui étaient isolés
dans leur campagne qui la civilisation
n'est pas encore arrivée jusque là et à
qui on a pris peut-être pris leur terre
aussi non
que tu es abandonné donc ils sont sortis
de l'histoire bloqués voilà comme ça
dans un espace-temps
et ils ont été d'ailleurs les premières
rejoindre les mouvements révolutionneurs
ce qui est venu principalement des zones
rurales citadins ont rejoint beaucoup
plus tard et forcé je dirais donc ce
passé passe mal et d'ailleurs les
présidents quand ils vont en Algérie
on visite officielle ou en visite d'État
c'est jamais très simple c'est toujours
compliqué on l'a vu encore récemment
avec
Emmanuel Macron qui a eu du mal à fixer
son agenda parce que bien le pouvoir
vous voyez d'un mauvais œil ce qui
pouvait faire ici ou là on va on va
regarder deux ou trois extrêmes vous
allez voir de tout ça
la liesse est impressionnante dépassant
parfois les services d'ordre Jacques
Chirac est ici le président d'une France
envier pour son niveau économique d'une
France ou de nombreuses algériens
voudraient vivre
même s'ils aiment d'abord leur pays nous
avons un passé commun il est complexe
douloureux
et
il a pu parfois
comme empêcher de regarder l'avenir
alors voilà Jacques Chirac on se
souvient c'était en 2003 on demande des
visas
et
Macron finalement c'est la même chose on
lui a demandé des visas aussi il y a eu
le Irak pourtant il y a eu ce mouvement
qui est né en 2000 en 2019
populaire plutôt bon enfant d'ailleurs
pour se révolter contre le régime pour
il y a une espèce de dégagisme qui était
réclamé puis finalement il y a eu la
crise sanitaire et tout ça ça a été
enterré d'une ça a jamais marché et le
régime est toujours là je dirais
l'état profond algérien est toujours là
la France officielle n'a jamais traité
qu'avec le pouvoir c'est un pouvoir de
fait il est là peut-être qu'à certaines
on voit des photos de l'Irak c'est des
photos des démonstrations de rue qui
avait lieu tous les vendredis
voilà la France a fait le choix la
France officielle de traiter avec
l'Algérie officielle voir de faire une
dictature militaro policière qui qui
comme l'a dit Macron vit sur la rente
historique
nous sommes les libérateurs nous avons
libéré le pays le pays nous appartient
nous sommes légitimes et voilà c'est
avec nous qu'il faut discuter nous
représentons le peuple donc vous dites
que la France a eu tort de continuer à
parler avec le régime alors que la
population se révoltait absolument
moi je pense que oui
je dirais pas qu'elle a tort ça a été il
est mal conseillé et mal préparé mal
préparé voilà il faut du temps il faut
préparer le terrain à différents niveaux
il aurait dû tenter de rencontrer la
société civile ce qui n'a pas fait
voilà donc vous remettez un petit peu en
question aussi les conclusions de la
commission Stora donc la commission
storage c'est une commission qui a été
installée à la demande de Emmanuel
Macron par Benjamin Stora qui est un
grand historien qui est de lui-même
natif d'ailleurs l'Algérie c'est un juif
d'Algérie il a créé cette commission et
cette commission est chargée justement
de trouver des moyens d'apaiser les
relations entre la France et l'Algérie
l'ouverture des archives enfin autant de
choses comme ça c'est conclusions vous
les nous estimez qu'elles sont bonnes ou
au contraire vous voulez c'est pas ça
qui a été revenu
Macron était rouler dans la farine ah
oui il était question au départ que les
deux gouvernement désigne chacun sa
commission donc Commission française
présidé par Benjamin Stora
et qui un mois après ou deux mois après
a rendu son rapport il faut ce qu'ils
ont pas eu l'équivalent en Algérie
président désigné mais pas
officiellement à certains monsieur chéri
qui est
directeur de des Archives nationales et
conseiller du président en matière
d'histoire et de d'archives
et n'a pas produit une demi-ligne
normalement en France ils auraient dû
arrêter il n'aurait pas dû commencer le
travail avant que la partie algérienne
ne commence elle-même voilà c'est un
travail à deux donc en fait
c'est pas contradictoire donc on peut
rien dire du rapport de de Benjamin
Sauvat il faudrait le comparer à quoi
si on avait un rapport chéri voilà
où les points de vue se rapprochent et
voilà où il s'écarte et on aurait fait
peut-être une troisième commission pour
précisément ces points de divergence ça
s'est passé il y a pas eu une seule
déclaration pas une réunion de la partie
algérienne voilà la partie française a
été rouler dans la farine Macron se
retrouve avec un rapport que faire si il
ne fait rien il va déplore à Alger voilà
Benjamin Stora propose ceci et cela vous
ne faites rien donc en fait politique le
discours des Algériens c'est toujours
plus loin quoi dans la repentance et pas
dans la dans la préparation la
manipulation le pouvoir algérien est
issu d'une révolution c'est encore il
fonctionne sur le paradigme de la
Révolution tout est caché sauf moi c'est
à la mort de Boumédiène que j'ai appris
que Monsieur Boumédiène ne s'appelait
pas me le dire c'était un nom de guerre
que le patron des services secrets
monsieur casino mirba c'était pas son
vrai nom c'est un nom de guerre il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vivent dans le
camouflage c'est la culture de la
Révolution ils sont battus dans la
clandestinité enfin c'est une une armée
très puissante des services secrets très
puissants et donc voilà
et c'est resté et c'est tellement
c'était tellement bénéfique alors je
reprends le mot bienfait c'était
tellement bénéfique pour le pouvoir
qu'il a gardé la chose on sait pas qui
décide en Algérie on sait pas qui se
réunit avec qui qui représente qui qui
représente quoi et pourquoi et puis vous
domino à longueur de journée
qu'on revienne sur bon il y a l'Algérie
et l'Algérie en Afrique souvent
l'Afrique elle a la pâte très bonne
presse
de par le monde parce que pour des
raisons multiples et variées et pourtant
elle a beaucoup d'atouts elle a une
richesse de sous-sol elle a une
population jeune néanmoins bon elle est
souffre de multiples mots
ici ou là la famille le réchauffement
climatique et puis alors il y a un de
vos chevaux de bataille c'est
l'islamisme en 1999 vous sortez un livre
de serment des barbares qui va faire
beaucoup de bruit quand même c'est là où
vous alerter d'une certaine façon vous
allez rester un peu l'Occident avec ce
livre sur les ravages que ça peut faire
oui absolument
c'était pourtant très visible l'islam
est une entité qui a sa propre vie
l'islam est un
processus historique qui avance avec ou
sans nous il avance il avance donc
le monde musulman a vécu le
démantèlement de l'empire ottoman
l'humiliation supra l'islam était en
train de mourir il perdait ce qui était
son essence même le calife donc au début
du XXe siècle de Dieu et du Prophète sur
terre alors les Occidentaux ont fait une
erreur colossale c'est d'enlever le
calife il fallait garder même comme ça
attacher à sa chaise il fallait le
garder symbole
et à cette époque est né
cet humiliation à
créer un mot qui a fait Florence dans
l'ensemble du monde musulman c'est le
mot nada qui veut dire Renaissance il
faut absolument se battre pour remettre
l'Islam sur ses rails problème religieux
à travailler comment remettre
l'islam dans sa revanche
après coup prophétique donc reprenons le
chemin qui est le site de l'islam on est
passé à l'islamisme après alors c'est la
même chose c'est un islamisme est un mot
il vient de l'histoire en France pour ne
pas pour ne pas froisser les musulmans
quoi c'est un mot qui n'existe pas dans
le monde musulman moi j'ai jamais
entendu le mot islamiste en Algérie on
parle de bons musulmans et mon vieux
musulman alors vous vous dénoncez tout
cela et vous en avez écrit vous avez une
une
œuvre qui est extrêmement riche très
intéressante passionnante et vous
continuez à vivre en Algérie vous n'avez
pas peur pour vous
écouter j'ai eu peur
autant de Gia donc pendant la guerre
civile algérienne
entre 1990 et 2000 le fils d'abord il y
a la période du fils c'est à dire on va
dire
85 par là jusque
12 93 par là les islamistes ont cherché
à s'attirer les bonnes grâces des élites
au pouvoir et on a besoin de ces gens-là
nous étions pour eux de quoi peut rendre
technique et puis bon le fils est passé
arrive les gilets jaunes c'est très
brutal qui n'est pas avec nous et contre
nous voilà et donc là vous manifestez
que vous êtes contre contre eux vous
devenez un ennemi voilà c'est comme ça
que là j'ai eu peur parce que ils ont
créé une section spéciale qui s'appelle
le sida
spécifiquement d'assassiner les
journalistes les intellectuels
les islamistes maintenant sont dans une
sur la même longueur d'onde que les
islamistes en France c'est-à-dire la
gyprope dans les banlieues on s'installe
on traverse les autorités c'est de
l'emprise
et tout le reste caché
voudrais quand même dire parce que vous
êtes vous êtes assez sombre dans le
constat que vous faites mais vous êtes
aussi assez optimiste pour l'avenir et
vous gardez en tous les cas espoir parce
que vous avez écrit en 2000 en 2021 un
livre qui s'appelle lettre d'amitié de
respect et de mise en garde au peuple et
aux nations de la terre c'est en fait un
manifeste qui est assez intéressant
parce que vous dites bah unissons-nous
puis ça ira beaucoup mieux vous êtes
quand même
vous gardez espoir quoi
d'abord ce livre ce livre fait suite à
un livre qui était post restante Alger
et être de colère d'espoir à mes
compatriotes donc il y a 10 ans alors je
m'adresse
enfin vous passez votre temps on passe
notre temps à nous plaindre agissons
et il vaut mieux accepter pour de bon
peut-être même rallier le pouvoir
mais si on se plaint se battre est un
devoir d'accord voilà si on se bat pas
on se la ferme d'accord et
j'avais j'avais titré cette lettre post
restante vous savez qu'elle n'arriverait
pas assez destinataires évidemment ce
livre était interdit et puis après je me
suis dit il y a une évolution dans le
monde c'est qu'il y a plus de problèmes
particuliers il n'y a plus que des
problèmes généraux mon problème c'est le
vôtre
on peut pas y échapper donc il faut
traiter ça
à l'échelle universelle voilà à
l'échelle universel et vous êtes
universaliste et je suis je le suis
alors donc je m'adresse un peu à ce qui
officiellement représente
l'universalisme c'est l'ONU
avant de se quitter je voudrais que vous
me répondiez à petit questionnaire
quel est votre musique préférée en
Afrique là j'ai découvert comme moi je
suis un fan de Kate bien sûr
de son fils amazir Kateb qui est un
chanteur et il chante le bonheur
c'est une musique il y a un festival
d'ailleurs tous les ans je crois
alors c'est à la fois
religieux politique c'est un truc très
compliqué
il y a du religieux c'est de la vaudou
un peu de vaudou aussi absolument
et là il a dans ce mouvement Gnawa il
est en train d'innover
introduit une instrumentation moderne
mais
il met un peu il ne fait pas que de la
politique il fait un peu de l'incitation
à la révolte d'accord c'est un peu en
fait je pense que bientôt il va
remplacer ce que le rail a été il y a 20
ans d'accord c'est une musique aussi
revendicative revendication comme ça
clandestine pour échapper à la police et
tout ça
cette particularité aussi si je vous
demande une ville quelle est la ville en
Afrique que vous préférez
Marrakech mais pas pour son côté comme
ça
pas du tout c'est que on ne s'intéresse
pas assez à cette cette région qui est
absolument d'une richesse historique
considérable alors oui au pire de
l'assurance c'est là que son nez
les deux dynasties islamiques les plus
qui nous inspirent jusqu'à aujourd'hui
qui ont inspiré c'est daesh voilà
c'est un Marrakech qui est né la
dynastie
almorade
puissance 10 et cette empire s'est
constitué qui a gouverné tout le Maghreb
et toute l'Espagne mais vous qui êtes
foncièrement vis-à-vis de l'islam qui
avait beaucoup de prévention pour il
faut étudier ces choses-là ah d'accord
parce que là on a vu ce que
l'islam en tant que religion je dirais
il est je dirais pas qu'elle est
inoffensive mais bon
la politique en tant que en tant que
politique on peut pas dire qu'elle est
inoffensive mais mettez-les ensemble et
c'est du plus étonnant d'accord
c'est ce qui s'est passé
un écrivain j'ai découvert
à cette époque là moi je venais de
sortir mon premier livre mon deuxième et
j'ai fait plusieurs tournées avec lui
j'ai découvert un homme absolument
extraordinaire Amadou Kourouma de
Kourouba
n'est pas obligé voilà et qui m'a appris
qu'il avait été réfugié politique en
Algérie
et qui connaissait l'Algérie alors que
lui était d'origine guinéenne et né en
Côte d'Ivoire voilà et c'est un très
grand écrivain qui est aujourd'hui décès
de grand
une connaissance de de connaissance de
l'Afrique absolument prodigieuse et dans
c'est très fin quoi c'est dommage qu'on
n'est pas assez profité de lui
merci Boualem sans salles merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup